jorge lopez six foot three two and five
pounder he has been much better his last
three times out including against boston
only allowed four runs in his last three
starts they're starting to turn the
corner the three two three
so here is voight and he is looking for
his first hit the one-two
there's a base hit to left field
boyd's first hit of the year as lamehu
advances to second
well you can see the smile on his face
he's feeling pretty good about picking
up his first hit of the year 3-1
and the bases are loaded
well now he has to come right at geo
urchella no place to put him bases
loaded nobody out one two on the way
he got him looking one down now that's
some high octane stuff in the hardest
fastball i've ever seen jorge lopez
we've seen a bunch of 97s but never a 98
and i mean paints it right on the
outside part in a huge first out here in
the top of the first inning
that one gets past cisco good heads up
base running by lemayo he never
hesitated and he scores the first run of
the game ball had a lot of movement
hit the webbing of the glove
and it goes back uh towards the backstop
and you're right lemayo was right on
point scores the first run of the game
3-1
rounded up the middle improve for a base
hit one run scores
judge will score it's a two-run single
for sanchez and the yankees lead three
nothing
barry sanchez recently has been starting
to swing the bat a little bit better he
had a good series down at tampa bay
and this will do a lot for his psyche
right here
right back through the middle
both runners score easily
lopez dug himself a hole this inning and
the yankees are covering him with third
sanchez short lead off the first
and he got him two down
so struck out rochelle with a good
fastball in 98 and here's the breaking
ball two different breaking balls one's
a slider this is a more
traditional 12 to six type breaking ball
right underneath the bet
or brett gardner oh two to one
bounce to the left side franco grabs it
steps on the bag for the force out and
the innings over but not before the
yankees put three up start number seven
on the season coming up for hermione and
you can see the numbers is recorded two
and two one of those wins came against
baltimore he's been very consistent his
last four starts he's come up with one
walk and six strikeouts each and every
one of them
rounded right to voigt
one away
strike three
hayes down looking in three pitches and
he's out of there and this is the worst
pitch of the punch kind of just a
spinning slider the o2
mancini lofts one to right center and
frazier makes the call on the catch
orioles go down in order against german
yankees sent eight to the plate in the
first inning so tyler wade the number
nine hitter lead off here in the second
bounce to the left side
in the dirt it gets away from mancini
and wade on on the air
there he goes wade on the run and they
got him chance cisco's done it again
well it doesn't matter now does it
no chance cisco erases tyler wade and
chancisko is much improved throwing this
year at six for nine ben and i think
that leads to major leagues six caught
stealing
there's a ground ball through the right
side for base hit for le mayhew
and it'll be an o2 to judge swung on and
hit in the air to left that ball is high
it is far it is gone
a judging blast
he hammers his third home run of the
series to deep left
field he all rise
here comes the judge
you know when he gets on one of these
streaks and this is why you you watch
that he's gonna be okay he's this is a
different team when aaron judges in the
middle of the lineup it just is
11 home runs now for judge six of them
against baltimore here come the orioles
in the third inning trailing five to
nothing organs haven't had a base runner
in the first two innings
first pitch swinging a base hit so rio
ruiz the orioles first base runner of
the game and the pitch is cut out
do it by him and there's one away
2-1 pitch
that's hit hard
in the gap and left center they won't
get that one
ruriz into third
and chancisko's got a loud double
and he lost him
so the base is loaded
[Applause]
this could be two there's one on to
first
it's a double play
a 5-4-3 double play gets the yankees out
of all that trouble in the inning and
domingo jorman goes into the fifth
inning pitching a shutout
severino right off the thumbs
test out that old glove went away
now herman's o2
struck him out swinging fastball
and a miss
strong inning as he works one two three
and we go to the sixth
so as we go to the sixth inning three
shutout innings so far for aiken
and there's a base hit to left field
fought it off and
found a hole
so gardner leads off with a single
[Applause]
and there's a base hit
and duhar now with the second hit of the
year gardner advances to second
[Applause]
fly ball shallow left gonna be a tough
play for hayes he dives he can't make
the play scrambles after it and all the
runners advance one base so another hit
for wade he's three for three well that
is going to do it for keegan aiken they
will go to the bullpen base is loaded
one man out yankees lead five nothing
dj le mayhew there's a ball and there's
a ball
how about a way to start off your relief
appearance by balking in a run
so gardner will score at six nothing
yanks
2-2
now on his rip face it to left field
and duhar scores wade's coming home the
throw nut in time it's a two-run single
for voight and the yankees lead eight
nothing
what'd you say michael he's getting
closer right
he was very close on this one he was all
over it in fact
second hit of the night for luke boyd
solid single to left field
hayes is going to make the throw but
wade is much too fast
scores standing up
here's cedric
blind drive hit streak extended one more
game now it's a nine game hit streak
two on nobody down
now face mancini cisco's at third and
hayes at first first pitch is grounded
up the third base line backhanded by
your shell off balance throw to first
voight holds the bag at first as
mancini's gone but cisco comes down to
score and the orioles on the board in
the sixth it's 8-1 new york
strike three outside corner a backdoor
breaking ball so in the inning for the
orioles to get on the board one run one
hit and one left now at the end of six
innings of play it's 8-1 yanks yankees
up 8-1 over the orioles as we head to
the top of the eighth inning we got a
new pitcher tyler wells is out sean
armstrong is in
and down he goes
andahar called out on strikes
one down in the eighth armstrong a
little front door starts on the inside
part of play watch that little slider
break right back over the inside part
not this time down on strikes he goes so
back to back strikeouts for sean
armstrong and armstrong looks good he's
had some struggles this year has been
kind of a mixed bag for him but he looks
really good here in the eighth he
punches out on do hard looking
and throws a really good slider
down and end and underneath the bat of
tyler wade armstrong trying to strike
out the side ahead two strikes
bounced down to mount castle he'll take
it himself armstrong with a good inning
yankees retired in order in the eighth
and luis sessa will try to get those
final three outs
lined up the middle base hit
austin hayes around third he will score
and arias has an rbi base hit and it's
eight to two
and the 2-2 is hit on the ground too
short lemay who steps on second throws
to first double play ball game over
yankees win
[Applause]
yankees
win
so after the yankees started off five
and ten
they are now 17 and seven